hi guys oh my god this is so awesome
this so I think the funniest thing about
making a movie like this is you deal you
when you come into it you're talking to
everybody about Wonder Woman Big Ideas
big things and then it slowly whittles
it's way smaller and smaller and so
you're sitting in an editing room by
yourself with Wonder Woman and your love
of Wonder Woman and that's where I am
right now so to come back out and oh my
god a woman if other people who love
Wonder Woman it's awesome so it's super
nice to be here I I'm super excited
you're all here I want to bring out this
was one of those incredible experiences
where like we have such an awesome cast
overall but the three people who are
here today are so near and dear to my
heart an incredible cast members and
they also really just happen to be they
brought such beautiful spirit true their
true spirit to the characters they play
the first one being we needed we needed
someone fit to be a queen someone who
was was worthy enough to be the mother
of Wonder Woman noble strong beautiful
but fierce when she needs to she
impressed me more every day that we shy
I want to bring out Connie Nielsen
Hippolyta
all right and she's amazing right you
see okay now then the next person is
somebody who was actually one of the
hardest and scariest casting I've ever
done in my life because I never wanted
to cast a sidekick to Wonder Woman I
wanted somebody unbelievable to be by
Wonder Woman side somebody's strong
powerful brave cool as hell
a real counterpart and somebody who you
would actually easily does you know who
who's also the kind of guy who's so
funny and cool that it would never be
emasculated by Wonder Woman he's the one
by her side saying that's pretty awesome
and he's the greatest human being and
one of the greatest actors I've ever
worked with my dear friend Chris Pine
Oh
all right now I think you know last but
far from least the most incredible thing
to me in the world was coming onto this
movie being very picky about casting
myself and having liked who could play
Wonder Woman well let me tell you
something I cannot wait for the world
you already love her but I cannot wait
for the world to love her as dearly and
passionately as everyone that made this
movie does because let me tell you what
she is Wonder Woman not just on the
screen which she's amazing but as a
person she is the kindest strongest
smartest most capable and badass human
being comes from the best place all the
time we all stood in parkas as she ran
into the sub 40 degree weather was like
that's okay guys is this the right thing
let's do it then man I'm gonna do it
she's amazing and one of my favorite
people in the whole world my dear friend
gal gadot
that looked amazing that was incredible
gah let's start with you
you are embodying this character you are
doing it so brilliantly tell us about
the experience of taking on this role
some oxygens into my brain first of all
thank you all for coming here today and
and and sharing your love and your
support to this character thank you so
much it's not to be taken for granted
now for your question I forgot it good
god you're taking on the role of Wonder
Woman and you're doing it perfectly in
all of our opinion what is involved when
you take on this role of being Wonder
Woman
was that feel like a great
responsibility to you first of all it's
it's an honor and it's a privilege you
know to be giving the opportunity of
portraying this character Wonder Woman
has the heart of a human and the
strength of a goddess and the
combination between the two is very very
powerful I remember before we started
shooting the movie I was I watched a
documentary movie about the real
Princess Diana where she said that she
leads from her heart and not from her
hand and I think that this quote
describes our Diana best I'm sorry I'm
shaking my voice is shaking everything
is out of control and then Singh Lamba
from within so I'm sorry
and yes knowing how many people care so
much for this character I do feel the
responsibility and for me as an actress
it was important to portray this
character in a way that everyone can
relate to Patti you tell us why Wonder
Woman is such an important hero for
right now these times it's actually
funny it's not funny at all but the way
news has been going and it's so hard to
be making like
a movie and paying attention to other
things when these horrible things are
happening in the world but honestly it's
one of the reasons that we it's
something we all believed in making the
movie in the first place which was the
world needs love and forgiveness in such
a huge way it's not about who's right
anymore it's got to be about it stopping
and having heroes who are strong enough
to be loving and forgiving and beautiful
and kind and and and not that there
aren't lots of them but it's what one
woman in particular stands for is being
like loving and amazing and incredible
at the same time and so like I couldn't
believe in the message of it more where
I'm like that's right be a hero but be
like a beautiful kind loving person who
who's fighting for the right thing
always and even has the ability to be
forgiving and move forward because you
are loving character that that's that's
press uh you narrowly beat me out for
the part of Steve Trevor not funny not a
laugh line at all something that's
highly plausible
tell us about Steve Trevor I saw your
audition tape it was pretty good yeah
wasn't that pretty good I should never
have taken off our hair match where I
lost CSUN hi Steve Trevor yeah I think
it's a pretty simple and wonderful
dynamic really I mean with Diana Prince
you have someone who's kind of a newbie
neophyte to the world of of men who has
great hope for Humanity and you have
Steve Trevor who lives right in the
heart of darkness in the world of men
and who has seen the awful depths and
depravity which mankind is capable of
exhibiting and from that kind of
hopeless state from that very hopeful
State these two meet they learn a little
bit you know about each other in the
world she the kind of jaded reality what
it means to be a human in real life and
for Steve Trevor a man who's lost all
kinds of hope in
time to learn a bit more about hope and
the the potential positive future of
mankind alright and Connie and this is
that question for Connie and n goes well
you two have to do a lot of training to
fight in this film and a lot of action
and yet use swords I mean tell us how
difficult was that how much training was
involved did you enjoy that aspect of
the job I absolutely felt so privileged
to be doing this six hours a day two
hours of the of weight training two
hours of writing in two hours of sort
train there was a lot of people in my
neighborhood who realized that I was
doing sword training because you know we
had to do it outside that couldn't do it
inside my house it was just not good for
my furniture and I'm standing outside
with my trainer and I'm getting into
these incredible poses and warrior poses
and there is a guy who is up in one of
the pile you know one of the big sort of
like electrical um what I called you
made flags oh yes uh-huh
telephone line things Oh Paul is called
that's the technical term and he's
sitting up there and he's repairing it
and and it was sudden he turns and he
sees me and the trainer and he literally
almost falls out of that little box up
there and I said maybe we should take
this indoors after all it was a
fantastic
you almost I know the man is what you're
saying that's very good alright I think
we want to get to some questions from
the audience uh I was told we have some
audience Q&A yes right over here I see a
light and I see a gentleman and a
microphone uh Patti one take a bow
Galip I'm saying this right toda for
responding to us on Twitter and for last
June's exact same Hall for standing up
that young kid whose friends made fun of
him for wearing a Wonder Woman t-shirt I
thought was very proud of you
so question is I don't Patti let you
answer do you fly or do we get the plane
uh well we cannot talk although they
have released that the invisible jet is
not in this movie but it might be in the
future and you know and no there's
there's a lot of exciting things but it
takes place in such an early period that
it wouldn't have been I don't think it
would have been the jet we want also if
it were there you wouldn't know it I
think we have time for just one more
question we only have time for two
questions yeah sorry that's what they're
telling me this is not my show I have no
power here oh hi my name is sky and my
question is for gal um how do you
prepare for your own and can you show me
your best Wonder Woman pose
well sky thank you for asking um
thankfully I have I have the best team
to work with me Patti I couldn't ask for
a better director to direct me in this
movie it's been such an amazing
experience she's my new sister we've
been working on this movie for six
months and we've been shooting six days
a week every week and on our one day off
we were like so do you have plans for
the weekend should we look at things
again so no but yeah but what I'm trying
to say is I did a lot of work I did a
lot of physical work and I did a lot of
research on the character and for me the
most important thing was really to to
portray this character in a way that
everyone can relate to not only girls
not only boys but men and women as well
cuz she has such a beautiful universal
story uh
and and being able to work with such a
fantastic cast members it's been a blast
and I couldn't ask for more
now for the pose I don't have my
bracelets with me right now so I hope
nothing's gonna happen
with me the one
well that works for me thank you to the
cast and uh thank you so much the movie
hits theaters June 2nd 2017 everyone
clearly looking forward to it one guy
shouting out but no one can really hear
them let's hear it for these guys
casting director
you